this is Startalk oh yeah it's guys you
know cuz tomorrow is Back to the Future
2 day just so you know in case you
didn't know where do you rank two in the
in the trilogy I ranked it second I
ranked the third third it's not just me
that's not my personal odd opinion I
think everyone would agree with that
ranking and so but yeah so back to the
future - as you know prophesized I don't
even call it a prediction it's a
prophecy that the Cubs would sweep the
World Series on October 21st in the Year
2015 and so tomorrow's - October 21st
there are more games played now then
back then so the the playoffs extend
almost to the beginning of November so
we'll see the Cubs look really good this
year but - playing the Mets and I think
the Mets look better so as a New Yorker
I want to lose for the Mets you know I'm
really Anki fan and but as a geek we
have to fulfil the geeky prophecy
we must it is the prime directive of the
D covers they geek prophecies come true
so that is I'm torn I'm torn
you